I've been requested to do a
video on the cross product,
and its special circumstances,
because I was at the point on
the physics playlist where I had
to teach magnetism anyway,
so this is as good a time as any
to introduce the notion of
the cross product.
So what's the cross product?
Well, we know about vector
addition, vector subtraction,
but what happens when you
multiply vectors?
And there's actually two ways to
do it: with the dot product
or the cross product.
And just keep in mind these
are-- well, really, every
operation we've learned is
defined by human beings for
some other purpose, and there's
nothing different
about the cross product.
I take the time to say that
here because the cross
product, at least when I first
learned it, seemed a little
bit unnatural.
Anyway, enough talk.
Let me show you what it is.
So the cross product of two
vectors: Let's say I have
vector a cross vector b, and the
notation is literally like
the times sign that you knew
before you started taking
algebra and using dots and
parentheses, so it's
literally just an x.
So the cross product of vectors
a and b is equal to--
and this is going to seem very
bizarre at first, but
hopefully, we can get a little
bit of a visual feel of what
this means.
It equals the magnitude of
vector a times the magnitude
of vector b times the sine of
the angle between them, the
smallest angle between them.
And now, this is the kicker, and
this quantity is not going
to be just a scalar quantity.
It's not just going
to have magnitude.
It actually has direction, and
that direction we specify by
the vector n, the
unit vector n.
We could put a little
cap on it to show
that it's a unit vector.
There are a couple of things
that are special about this
direction that's
specified by n.
One, n is perpendicular to
both of these vectors.
It is orthogonal to both of
these vectors, so we'll think
about it in a second
what that implies
about it just visually.
And then the other thing is the
direction of this vector
is defined by the right
hand rule, and we'll
see that in a second.
So let's try to think
about this visually.
And I have to give you an
important caveat: You can only
take a cross product when
we are dealing in three
dimensions.
A cross product really has--
maybe you could define a use
for it in other dimensions or a
way to take a cross product
in other dimensions, but it
really only has a use in three
dimensions, and that's useful,
because we live in a
three-dimensional world.
So let's see.
Let's take some cross
products.
I think when you see it
visually, it will make a
little bit more sense,
especially once you get used
to the right hand rule.
So let's say that
that's vector b.
I don't have to draw a
straight line, but it
doesn't hurt to.
I don't have to draw
it neatly.
OK, here we go.
Let's say that that is vector
a, and we want to take the
cross product of them.
This is vector a.
This is b.
I'll probably just switch to one
color because it's hard to
keep switching between them.
And then the angle between
them is theta.
Now, let's say the length of a
is-- I don't know, let's say
magnitude of a is equal to
5, and let's say that the
magnitude of b is equal to 10.
It looks about double that.
I'm just making up the
numbers on the fly.
So what's the cross product?
Well, the magnitude
part is easy.
Let's say this angle is
equal to 30 degrees.
30 degrees, or if we wanted
to write it in radians, I
always-- just because we grow
up in a world of degrees, I
always find it easier to
visualize degrees, but we
could think about it in terms
of radians as well.
30 degrees is-- let's see,
there's 3, 6-- it's pi over 6,
so we could also write
pi over 6 radians.
But anyway, this is a 30-degree
angle, so what will
be a cross b?
a cross b is going to equal
the magnitude of a for the
length of this vector, so it's
going to be equal to 5 times
the length of this b vector, so
times 10, times the sine of
the angle between them.
And, of course, you
could've taken the
larger, the obtuse angle.
You could have said this was the
angle between them, but I
said earlier that it was the
smaller, the acute, angle
between them up to 90 degrees.
This is going to be sine of 30
degrees times this vector n.
And it's a unit vector, so I'll
go over what direction
it's actually pointing
in a second.
Let's just figure out
its magnitude.
So this is equal to 50, and
what's sine of 30 degrees?
Sine of 30 degrees is 1/2.
You could type it in your
calculator if you're not sure.
So it's 5 times 10 times 1/2
times the unit vector, so that
equals 25 times the
unit vector.
Now, this is where it gets,
depending on your point of
view, either interesting
or confusing.
So what direction is this
unit vector pointing in?
So what I said earlier is, it's
perpendicular to both of these.
So how can something be
perpendicular to both of these?
It seems like I can't
draw one.
Well, that's because right here,
where I drew a and b,
I'm operating in
two dimensions.
But if I have a third dimension,
if I could go in or
out of my writing pad or, from
your point of view, your
screen, then I have a vector
that is perpendicular to both.
So imagine of vector that's-- I
wish I could draw it-- that
is literally going straight in
at this point or straight out
at this point.
Hopefully, you're seeing it.
Let me show you the
notation for that.
So if I draw a vector like this,
if I draw a circle with
an x in it like that, that is a
vector that's going into the
page or into the screen.
And if I draw this, that is a
vector that's popping out of
the screen.
And where does that convention
come from?
It's from an arrowhead,
because what does
an arrow look like?
An arrow, which is our
convention for drawing
vectors, looks something like
this: The tip of an arrow is
circular and it comes to a
point, so that's the tip, if
you look at it head-on, if it
was popping out of the video.
And what does the tail of
an arrow look like?
It has fins, right?
There would be one fin here
and there'd be another fin
right there.
And so if you took this arrow
and you were to go into the
page and just see the back of
the arrow or the behind of the
arrow, it would look
like that.
So this is a vector that's going
into the page and this
is a vector that's going
out of the page.
So we know that n is
perpendicular to both a and b,
and so the only way you can
get a vector that's
perpendicular to both of these,
it essentially has to
be perpendicular, or normal,
or orthogonal to the plane
that's your computer screen.
But how do we know if it's going
into the screen or how
do we know if it's coming out of
the screen, this vector n?
And this is where the right hand
rule-- I know this is a
little bit overwhelming.
We'll do a bunch of example
problems. But the right hand
rule, what you do is you take
your right hand-- that's why
it's called the right hand
rule-- and you take your index
finger and you point it in the
direction of the first vector
in your cross product,
and order matters.
So let's do that.
So you have to take your finger
and put it in the
direction of the first arrow,
which is a, and then you have
to take your middle finger and
point it in that direction of
the second arrow, b.
So in this case, your
hand would look
something like this.
I'm going to try to draw it.
This is pushing the abilities
of my art skills.
So that's my right hand.
My thumb is going to be
coming down, right?
That is my right hand
that I drew.
This is my index finger, and
I'm pointing it in the
direction of a.
Maybe it goes a little bit more
in this direction, right?
Then I put my middle finger, and
I kind of make an L with
it, or you could kind of say
it almost looks like you're
shooting a gun.
And I point that in the
direction of b, and then
whichever direction that your
thumb faces in, so in this
case, your thumb is going
into the page, right?
Your thumb would be going down
if you took your right hand
into this configuration.
So that tells us that the vector
n points into the page.
So the vector n has magnitude
25, and it points into the
page, so we could draw it
like that with an x.
If I were to attempt to draw
it in three dimensions, it
would look something
like this.
Vector a.
Let me see if I can give
some perspective.
If this was straight down, if
that's vector n, then a could
look something like that.
Let me draw it in the
same color as a.
a could look something like
that, and then b would look
something like that.
I'm trying to draw a
three-dimensional figure on
two dimensions, so it might look
a little different, but I
think you get the point.
Here I drew a and
b on the plane.
Here I have perspective
where I was able to
draw n going down.
But this is the definition
of a cross product.
Now, I'm going to leave it
there, just because for some
reason, YouTube hasn't been
letting me go over the limit
as much, and I will do another
video where I do several
problems, and actually, in the
process, I'm going to explain
a little bit about magnetism.
And we'll take the cross product
of several things, and
hopefully, you'll get a little
bit better intuition.
See you soon.